Jesse a lot of people are stocking up or
try have tried to stock up on
necessities what have you tried to stock
up on as best you can I mean I we went
to a gas station to buy paper towels and
there were two rolls and I felt so
guilty taking both I just took one and I
came back in to the RV my wife said what
the hell are you doing
yeah the other roll of paper towels I
said but what if somebody else needs
them and she said no one's going to a
gas station for paper towels and I
realized that's like a good adage to
have in an otherwise chaotic time so did
you go back and buy the other roll no
because I genja I feel horrible so I'm
using my dirty socks to stop up you know
puddles and stuff yeah well I think
that's Noble
that you decided to take both roles oh
yeah any indulgences that you've stocked
up on yeah I mean I I was trying to
actually before it happened I was trying
to gain weight for a movie and I was
eating a pint of Ben and Jerry's fudge
brownie and I was eating that every
night I'd microwave it for about five
seconds you can't see but I just
referenced where the microwave is and
and I I did find I found wine at a gas
station so I I ate it that night I
should have reckoned you know please
explain to me you microwave it for five
seconds to get it just a little bit soft
right it's it's it seems it's too it's
too much of a commitment eat a full pint
of frozen ice cream but if it's soft it
just feels like you know chicken soup or
something more yeah I'm all too eaten
that way curious you have made these
very well-known movies these Zombieland
movies about surviving in a situation
somewhat like the one we have now we're
not being chased by zombies but we are
you know battling an invisible foe we're
all right to take care of ourselves did
you learn anything have any of your
Zombieland skills been useful at all to
you during this pandemic
yeah no no it turns out it turns out
it's just a funny movie yeah
just a fun movie and a late sequel no I
mean you know the now the only thing
like my character has Purell with him
mime and even like set a joke in the
first movie about Purell I don't even
know if it was in the script so if I
made the joke then I in some way enhance
that brand and now I can't seem to find
a Purell anywhere right and not one rule
that would have been helpful is now a
practical impossibility yeah there is no
Purell
I bought expensive witch hazel the other
night which turns out is just um it just
tones the skin I thought oh this is
alcohol I can use no no no yes what do
you mean you bought witch hazel why
would you buy witch hazel who said to
buy that I was desperate I had the pint
of ice cream and I thought I need some
hand sanitizer I couldn't find anything
so I I just thought it was a sailor's
brand witch hazel I thought okay
worst-case scenario will have better
pores and it turns out worst case
scenario is come through you have
terrible skills terrible yes for
survival yes I know that when my wife is
coming in the RV I'm on the Conan
O'Brien show Oh God
we haven't happened anyway real life
folks I'm sorry sorry my my wife is Anna
my ass and in in what what am i Loftus
in this what's the we're we're dealing
these are dark times you're allowed to
say whatever you want it sounded to me
like you're somebody's hand in a pipe of
[ __ ] your son said in a punch in a pipe
of [ __ ] and then he just said it he just
repeated me cuz he yes yes yes okay this
is fine this is real life this is what's
happening
everyone's coping in their own way and
to recap Jesse Eisenberg is trapped in
an RV with his wife and son unless
Kansas the valve that allows him to get
rid of the excrement in the RV yeah
malfunctioning
and his son just put his hand into a
pipe of aforementioned [ __ ] is that
right that's it you sound like the
character on like a drama after a
commercial break straight coming
Jessie Aizen
I just think we're I think we're all
handling this in our own way and we're
doing the best we can